A popular landmark located at the summit of Montmartre,...
...Sacre Coeur is the highest point in the city,...
...and as a result offers some of the best views in all of Paris.
And the best part is, it's all free.
Sacre Coeur is also a great stop after a long walk through the streets of Paris,...
...where you can enjoy a picnic underneath this incredible church...
...while basking in the panoramic views of Paris.
Probably the most well-known cathedral in the entire world,...
...thanks in large part to Victor Hugo's novel, "The Hunchback of Notre Dame,"...
...is located on the eastern half on the Ile de la Cite along the Seine.
Due to its overwhelming popularity, it is best to visit Notre Dame during the week,...
...when lines to visit the top are shorter.
And be sure to check out the crypts of Notre Dame,...
...which is an often forgotten treasure of this cathedral.
As is without a doubt, the most famous attraction in all of Paris,...
...it is also the most populated, especially on the weekends.
So, it is best to visit the Eiffel Tower on weekdays,...
...and you must book your tickets in advance if you want to travel to the top of the tower.
Wait lines can exceed four hours,...
...and for those with a limited amount of time in Paris...
...can find themselves there for the entire day.